nothing can describe the fit and feel of
me undies and once you try them on
you'll understand why they're called the
world's most comfortable underwear and
if you don't love your first pair of
Mounties they're free no questions asked
you can support allegedly by going to
meet undies dot-com / funny f you in NY
where you'll receive 20% off your first
order that's right
20% off some wonderful junk covers you
heard it hear me undies dot-com / funny
for 20% off your first order thank you
for supporting allegedly me undies has
dozens of styles and limited edition
prints to help you make a statement with
your underwear make a statement support
allegedly me undies dot-com / funny I'm
Theo von and I'm Matthew Cole Weiss and
welcome to allegedly today you will know
his voice from the legends of Cora
Dragons race to the edge you'll know his
face from many places including one of
the greatest sitcoms of all time married
with children childhood and adult star
David Faustino thank you thank you thank
you thank you thank you thank you here
the bowels of the comedy scene yeah this
is our first time in this new room in
the Comedy Store and we are smelling the
paint yeah interview we might be
spilling it all yeah we'll be high by
the end of unbelievable yeah I'm good
ready for our Friday night it's funny
because last week we had Nolan Gould in
who was on the show Modern Family with
mr. Ed O'Neill yeah and so now we've got
a David Faustino who started the Ed
O'Neill sitcom yeah that's right hey man
I am responsible for ed O'Neill's career
yeah you guess you've guest-starred on I
did yeah I did one spot on yeah yeah
what's funny enough about that
is that is that you would think that
would have used that moment as like you
know one of those cool moments where we
didn't have a scene together at night
why I was just a pearlized on that and
yeah I just auditioned like I saw the
Royal come up in my man
like okay and I went and I auditioned
for it but there was no scenes with Edie
so it's kind of like a wasted
opportunity I thought for them which
could have been fun but yeah how bizarre
oh oh I got hit up like all over Twitter
and people that what the [ __ ] you
wouldn't know any seams with an like you
know so Curtis I take it right yeah yes
yes and did twitter try to blame it on
you isn't it weird out Twitter sometimes
people have no conscience your fault
what did you do scenes with it was under
my power I would have there are a lot of
angry people on Twitter yeah they're
actually a lot of celebrities like I was
listening to Stern and a lot of bigger
celebrities like I'm just I can't read
any of the comments anymore yeah or just
so mean
yeah I don't my fans are tremendous and
I don't really have that many haters I
guess that's not a good thing but most
of the fans I talked to have been great
to me so right I still check out my I
think one of the best pieces of advice I
have ever heard were with a project
you're doing you can't read the good or
the bad because when you read the good
you kind of like or that'll open the
door to reading the bad and then you'll
focus on the bad so just everybody yeah
exactly
yeah I just read it to you know here's
some God has hated me just so severely
that it just made me feel pretty sad for
about 11 blocks of driving yeah it's
weird like you know it's [ __ ] up when
someone said some shitty stuff about you
it was just some like troll yeah that's
like wait a minute now then I find
myself looking at his account to like
see who he like does he do this to
everyone or did he just do judging
character you know spent nine minutes on
this guy's like wait a second my latter
than this guy so it doesn't really
matter what are you doing today guy yeah
completely so the first thing is we're
gonna tell stories round one is we each
tell story you wanna go first or me
won't you go for it okay
so I have three minutes to tell my story
starting now I'm gonna tell I I
something tells me you have a lot of you
didn't know a lot of like cool things
and partied with some good people can't
even a man can't even imagine some of
the stories so I'm gonna tell one that
sort of happened to me I went to a roast
it was the roast a Comedy Central Roast
before they were like Justin Bieber or
Pamela Anderson where it was Rob Reiner
so this is when they were still trying
to do like there's a comedy sunglass see
yeah all the family from all in the
family you know so I went there and
of course you know these days are so
bizarre like the most random people they
have and one of the people on it for
whatever reason I have no idea was
Vanilla Ice right he's on the death he
was on the day yes I guess it was just
someone who you know you know like what
is this person like Ludacris was on the
last one exactly so that's ludicrous
right so I didn't know anybody and
vanilla and afterwards he did good but
afterwards were at the after-party he
didn't know anybody in the Rob Reiner
crowd for sure you know weird so we
ended up talking and he was really cool
and he says well what are you doing now
when I was like nothing this is when I
lived in New York and he's like do you
want to go to a strip club and I was
like okay yeah you need to invited the
weird [ __ ] Ben Affleck try to take him
out to party in college yeah he didn't
have any friends to take and I was like
okay and he goes it's in New Jersey and
I was like if we're going to going to
out in a strip club in New Jersey and
we're in New York and he says we're
gonna meet my buddy and I was like who's
your buddy
he's like do you know whoo tang clan and
I was like ish he goes you know
Ghostface Killah that was his name him
and vanilla vanilla ice and Ghostface
Killah our friends yes well they were
this was a good like decade ago you know
I'm sure being a young Jewish boarder
you call your mother and ask can I go
hang out with a man I think it was too
late because my mom was you know my mom
goes to sleep at 8:00 but I go space
killer was yeah forgetting a whole other
aspect to it which is I'm yay and I
don't I've been in a strip club once
before so that it wasn't and it wasn't a
male strip club like something definite
like but it was one of those experience
was like might as well just go with it
right so we go and we drive or we we
took a cab to like it was in Hoboken I
think and we go to the strip club and
immediately it's like let's get high and
I was like oh my god that's also
something I've really haven't done that
much right but when you're when you go
with that nurdle I was like I'm good
yeah this is the extent of me going
I'm gonna smoke weed and go to a strip
club right right and so we went and
Ghostface Killah was there he was
actually very nice for a man who has the
word killer in his name it was very nice
and it turned out to be exactly what you
would think it would be which is me kind
of sitting there like awkwardly like
this while Ghostface Killah Manila I so
like yeah you don't throwing money at
[ __ ] or whatever you call them these
days right and me feeling really
uncomfortable and me to the point where
I was like class tomorrow you know like
I gotta go back because I I was there
all the dopest [ __ ] gets wasted on him
oh yeah Ghostface Killah and that's my
time god thank you I know it was not
that good he brings next so I mean I've
definitely had some crazy times in this
town I'm sure everybody has right with
some drugs right so works yeah so one
night I met this girl at a club right
and she uh she she was kind of cool she
had kind of like uh I don't [ __ ] like a
big head or one of her arms is kind of
bigger whatever something was but I also
could have had like some in my eye maybe
I wasn't seeing things fully correct
right now normally large yes someone's
abnormally large right which is ironic
to the end of this story which when
things aren't abnormally large I was I
was going through a tough time I was
drinking I was drugging and uh and I
ended up doing a bunch of blow one night
right and got in touch with this gal
right so I don't know if ever even total
story like this on this have I met no
they haven't told any drug adventure on
stage I don't know if I told me this to
this extent so I go and pick up her
friend from this club from Warwick right
you're out there yeah I remember Warwick
yeah yeah no worries now or so now it's
kind of fading a little bit but yeah
when I first started popping spent about
three or four years now uh but anyway so
it was the same guy that owned like
LeDoux and stuff like that
Silvan Mike boogie if you know any of
those guys but so anyway I end up
picking up this girl and her friend from
the club we end up doing some blow right
so next you know I'm pretty geeked up
so then they interest me like this
geeked up and out east don't they say
gackt out
get down yeah I always heard eked up but
I liked it are you where are you from
I'm from Louisiana from Louisiana out
here I don't know what they say but out
east as always you get out y'all act out
yeah we're sure you haven't dude no weed
yeah yeah he got high ones with [ __ ]
I'm gonna like how an accident so what
happened was I end up they end up
meeting up with this dude this older guy
and I don't I can't figure out how they
know him there's always that guy in LA
where there's like hot chicks and you
don't know how they know this older dude
that's hanging around any drugs or money
but anyway next thing we end up at this
dude's mansion up in the hills but oh
wait first we went to like this weird
party where everybody looked like they
never had a day job in their life and
they just like lived in Hollywood I've
had nothing ever to do completely and
nobody was talking to everybody's on the
phone there's a million people there but
nobody was talking about I hate yes it
was miserable it was a and I don't go to
that kind of thing it was miserable so
then we went higher up the hill to this
dudes like mansion right Nate it was
10,000 square feet beautiful homes to
was probably bout 50 so he leaves off
with one of the girls and then so I'm
then hanging out with this one girl a
couple of other girls show up some
Persian dudes show up there's like
Lamborghinis in and out of garage I have
no concept of what's going on I just
continue to do coke right till I haven't
lost my [ __ ] mind I'm basically
wander around the toots house and don't
even know Coca oh just coked out row and
then repeatedly end up in like different
rooms with different women but I'm so
coked up I can't get an erection
yeah so I did just I start just I
basically become like the guy who's
doing oral sex so traumatic see either
going that room the [ __ ] eaters in
there he's like and like I mean and
there were so many great opportunity
like I was out on this balcony with
their smoke and I chicken like
bang me and I'm like I literally almost
just like threw off about but it feel
some impact
I love how different our lives are
because because every minute that's
three minutes the Koch are you done I
mean I was done whenever I got to the
party yeah and I'm done now what we're
glad she did he didn't murder the girl
yes no yeah but it was so seating weird
and then it ended like this I ended up
in like this threesome kind of exchange
so then not only was highlighting
individually now I had to get an amazing
opportunity to let two women down at
once Wow and if you've ever felt lower
like drugs will make you feel low in the
aftermath like this was right around
sunrise I mean the sun's coming up I'm
just doped out of my brain and I'm
letting two women down at once and then
some other dude came in bro like the
hero shot right right where some dude
comes in dick swinging I know him
knocked on the door I don't think he did
I think it's dick did there's something
hard right right they headed in that
directly all right so round one is over
mister Faustino you have to pick a
winner of that round based on whatever
you want any criteria it can anything
small or large
well because I'm from this town and I've
heard a lot of stories similar to yours
and maybe experienced something similar
and those stories are somewhat a diamond
Dez I'm not saying here's your story's
not great right but his story Matt right
yes is is is is just one of these
interesting stories because it's like he
ends up at the roast of Rob Reiner right
and then he ends up in Jersey with
Ghostface Killah and and and vanilla ice
it's just so random and and like I just
picture I'm like heading back to the
city just like paranoid and high and
just like grossed out and the [ __ ]
vagina that he just saw oh yes I was in
a strip club this the only other time no
I've been there one time since the girl
sat on my lap and she licked my ear and
I I was like what are you doing
literally pushed her out and I was like
because I have German shoes too
all right that is disgusting and we went
to the bathroom and I was like cleaning
out my ear and then I laugh well so I
win that round I will take it yeah very
much that one's around wow that was a
great round before we move on I want to
remind you that whether you're wearing a
suit or sweats you spend almost 24 hours
a day in your underwear wow that's a
long time but instead of making a
statement sometimes you're just not
making a statement well that can change
with me undies
every pair of my undies is made from
sustainably sourced mo doll
that's a fabric that's twice as soft as
cotton 2 times its softest cotton no way
yes way so saw nothing can describe the
fit and feel of me undies and once you
try them on you'll understand why
they're called the world's most
comfortable underwear and as a special
gift from us here at allegedly you can
go to me undies dot-com slash funny fu
in NY for 20% off your first order so if
you look into your pants right now and
your junk covers look a little weak time
to change your game they're for men's
and for women's is everybody can covered
a junk with me undies me undies dot-com
/ funny support allegedly 20% off and if
you don't enjoy your first pair of me
undies they are free that's right f our
ii ii ii ii ii undies comm / funny now
back to the episode alright moving on to
round 2 which is our interview segment
where now you are in the hot seat and we
get to ask you question all right now am
i judging something on this - or is it
just some italy at the end you get to
pick whoever's line of questioning or
tactics or the one off one off or you go
first in this case matt tends to haul
get because he's just like that but i
just want to be good interviews okay
and he just feels like i don't have that
capability that's fine
why don't you start us off then Thea
okay I will dude I'm gonna throw this um
do you feel like in Hollywood you either
get to be an adult star or a child star
hmm that's a really good question I
wouldn't say that because you can you
can use examples across the board of
both I mean there's a ton of big stars
today a list and maybe just a little bit
under the a-list who have started out as
child stars I mean there's a lot of them
out there right now they're huge that
started off as kids a lot of people
don't even know it
and then there's there's examples of you
know people who never worked again so I
think it just depends on your work ethic
your talent and your ability to push
forward right yeah
yeah cuz I always feel like as I get
older I mean the dream I feel like is to
be a star like to have kind of the
height of stardom around your teen and
like young too like you know cuz that's
like the [ __ ] like me got beat yeah
you know is it that good I mean that had
it is I mean it was great I I've had a
great time this town's been good to me
and I've partied all across this town I
mean I live right basically right behind
the store all nice and you know and and
it would it you know Fame at that age is
tremendous you know you look back and
it's like you know they say you what is
it youth is wasted on the young
yeah I mean if I knew now I would have
made a lot of different decisions but
you know you learn as you go right yeah
so you wouldn't if he could change it
mm-hmm
and not have this success at that age
would you or would you do this oh no I
would do I would do over again the same
way absolutely no regrets no regrets all
right well I mean well I regret some
choices I've made along the way yeah me
too now on everything you do you make
investments you you you you you decide
to own some restaurants you know I just
christina was like my sister so there
was nothing there he never thought about
you never know I mean I know we traveled
a couple times we were drunk and like
something could have happened like we
were like but it just we know we just
kept it because I'll be dead honest is
one of the posters I had on my wall
growing up was of Christina Applegate
and that like when I was pretending to
be straight and stuff for like
yeah there was Elvis fierson there was
Pamela Anderson and there was Christina
Applegate and Wallach why is this boy
looking the other way no joke Pamela
Anderson eventually when I became more
accepting I put Bette Midler's face over
there okay so sweet but no I just wanted
to relay one because you know you have
these people saying all this and I find
mostly black men are more interested in
in Katy no Katy oh wow what'd you find
white man are more interested and yeah
but why is that you think I have no I
think cuz of the tight pants the cheetah
print the cheetah that yeah but I was in
New York once and but this would this
goes against the story because it was a
guy talking about Christina but I'm
walking through New York everybody just
shot when you're when you're famous in
New York it's the most is the best
experience because everyone's just
yelling [ __ ] so I remember this guy's
walking past me and it's black dude he's
walking past me and he's like hey bud oh
man Oh Christina Applegate your sister
man I want to tap that you telling you
you could tell he was gonna say you tell
her I want to [ __ ] her you tell her I
want any pause you tell her I wanna did
you relay the message well no the
message I did relay to her is when the
Beatle yeah I can't believe I camera
George Harrison told me that he would
have liked to eat her [ __ ] Wow
and to tell her that she's probably
never met a [ __ ] licking Beatle before
and that's is that a true story absolute
true story yes yes he was a giant Mary
with children fan which is which was
yeah to find that out you know what I
mean to like meet George Harrison and be
like nervous as [ __ ] and then to find
out like he's this giant fan of Mary
with children was just surreal you know
and that he's a [ __ ] licking and that
is Ito click a click whatever it'll you
tell her I'm you know that I want to eat
her [ __ ] and I said when I when I left
I just made another like alluded to it I
alluded to it again saying I'm gonna let
her know he goes yeah yeah yeah you let
her know I bet she's never met a [ __ ]
licking Beatle before Wow
so I literally because they didn't have
work the very next day so
and I sat we were saw sitting on the
little Bundy couch on the set and I told
the whole cast the story that morning
they were just like Christine oh just
like red-faced they're just cracking up
Wow
actually you were quiet shy Beatle Wow
you win the story around by the way dude
I wonder if she's ever met like a butt
sex traveling Wilbury before sex
traveling what do you guys knew that
banisters yeah we'll take that right did
you know that Marcy Darcy was gay
I did and how it was that because it was
at a time when it wasn't not near as
acceptable or as cool did you feel like
you had to keep a secret or was it very
difficult
around that you know what I mean like
I'm just curious what it was like hmm
cuz you know Marcy Darcy oh yeah yeah I
don't think I realized I was a little
bit older obviously cuz like I said I
was 12 when I started almost 13 and then
she came out at some point I mean but
she came out before like she was one of
that wasn't she she was one of the
pioneers of that yeah sure yeah and it
didn't make much like headway though
like I ever feel like she would've had a
better now now yeah she was before her
time yeah actually I mean she got flack
for it whereas now accepted yeah good on
you and that time it was still not ready
yet I think and I'm just curious what it
was like around that when that you know
when that went down and it was cool I
mean I it wasn't anything to me be
honest with you just it was it just was
what it was and then I mean she had this
one girlfriend though that was but I
have I was like oh my god this chick is
hot
Amanda beers that's her name Amanda
burns yeah yeah cuz I remember I
remember distinctly when I found out I
was like wait like I I mean obviously
looking back the signs were there
but I remember heard her husband are the
same haircut
gay Zach I bet with it then I bet when
she feels gay - but he's probably drink
more and you would have to go for a run
in the more beer seems like you go for a
run in the morning but I bet when nah
when she heard that George Harrison
story I bet she was like I'll give
George a run for his money came in from
an animal lover uh [ __ ] the dog mm-hmm
passed away did you know did I know yeah
um yeah I knew I mean I grew up with the
dog so we didn't try to pull a fast one
on you and like replace it with yeah oh
no no no no I was sad I mean that dog
was like my friend is actually my real
name was Michael right yeah Mike the dog
and he was a great dog although one I
did have one experience with him we were
leaving we had that we were doing having
a wrap party you know we wrapped like
one of the seasons and that I was in you
know part of the dog the dog owner Steve
Steve Rick great guy we were inside were
party and having drinks or whatever and
I actually I wasn't having drinks
there's a little kid at the time so I
leave the wrap party and I see that his
truck is parked in the parking lot and
Buck is in the the part in the in the
truck and the windows down a little bit
well you know anything any person who
has any wisdom whatsoever knows you
don't approach a [ __ ] car with a dog
in it and put your hand and you know but
I knew this dog but he still was like yo
who's who's coming he almost took my
[ __ ] hand off yeah yeah I mean he
went he went crazy [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] yeah
buck he was he was a moody [ __ ] what
really was yeah he wasn't like the lazy
little like nothing dog like he had he
definitely had an attitude and when he
talked like what was that like it was he
said them really wise Hey what's so
funny about you you mentioned that it's
because we had so many different people
play like usually the main guy was just
one of the writers and he I thought was
the best Kevin Colonel guy named Kevin
current writer great writer he would
play cuz he just did this straight
no delivery no emotion whatsoever and I
thought he was the best but then they're
like when we did like a special episode
featuring buck they'd have like Cheech
Marin play him and then these other
people but I thought the best guy was
for sure no so
Mike unless you have a final question
yeah and so I know that now you do a ton
of voiceover work and that's been like a
kind of like a main theme in your life
it seems like over the past few years or
you know are part of a it's a giant pie
yeah um did buck did that influence you
at all oh that that stuff yeah um no
money yeah it's a fun I enjoy it I
really do enjoy right but I mean you
know at the end of the day it's a job
and I uh it's been great to me and I
love it yeah so you've talked recently
about married with children possibly
spin-off or reboot or something along
those lines I want to know a if you know
where that stands and B do you think
it's tame in today's consideration on TV
like do you think it would have to adapt
and even push the envelope because it
push the envelope for its time yeah but
now I mean like the envelope on TV is so
far yeah like do you think it would have
to push it completely over the edge to
stay in the game so to speak well answer
your first question a the answer to that
is um it is has been in the works for a
couple years the the whole cast has has
signed on to say and I mean not
physically signed but had said yes we
will recur it was it was kind of based
around you know Bud Bundy right and um
and Sony very very excited about it but
there has been one issue a legal issue
that they haven't been able to get
around at the moment that they're still
trying to work out which obviously we
all hope will work out as do the fans
but if it does it'll you'll see it and
if they can't figure this out then you
won't and in answer to your question I
think in ways it did it did push the
envelope but in ways we've become even
less accept like some of the jokes are
you could not get away with
you could not get away with a lot of the
[ __ ] that they said oh yeah they push
the envelope well these days a lot of
times I don't really know right like
after like then they did a real good job
I feel like it was there wasn't as much
fear it was just like let's be funny
right and and I mean I think the things
that would be different is like Kelly
would be even more like she'd be in a
g-string right exactly and you can get
away with stuff like that all right but
some of the jokes I mean all we did was
ride on fat people yeah and just it was
you know oh we never before we needed a
show like that I don't think it right
now what what's that
everybody's sick of all this other
[ __ ] like every show is like oh well
there's this there's a rumor that I'm
you know it we could end up on it on
Netflix and if I was just thinking how
fun marry what children would be on
Netflix because you know you could
really you could really have some fun
then yeah completely thank do you tell
Kelly to go [ __ ] off you could do a lot
of like fun things like I'd want that I
wouldn't want the full house thing which
is pretty much the same thing is it I
would want yeah you know you guys be
able to go that extra distance you know
and I think bud should be gay I think by
sexual total surprise the first time you
come down the stairs it's in heel right
in fans I feel like in Hollywood like as
far as like like everybody's careers it
seems like go kind of in cycles most
people do you feel like do you feel that
kind of in your career because you've
been in the business for so long I mean
do you feel like that because you can't
I mean the ability to stay on like the
top line of stardom forever is really
nearly one in a jillion yeah so do you
feel like it like things are cyclical
kind of or do you like yeah I mean again
it goes back to you know it goes back to
not having any control obviously because
this time is what it is but at the end
of the day you do have control over you
and what you choose to do I've you know
I've made a lot of poor decisions in my
life I could only you know I can only
I'm only at where I'm at for the the
the way I've lived my life and the
choices I've made and I don't blame this
town or anybody for what I am doing or
not doing I'm more positive now in my
life than I have been in a long time and
you know once I think what you change
your thinking around things start to
change in your life um but you know
voice-overs been so good to me had I not
had that as a backup I don't know what I
would be doing necessarily or how I
would feel about this town right but
since that door opened up to me about 15
years ago and I've made a great career
out of it
you know I'm blessed in that way but
yeah it is cyclical I think you just
have to hold on you keep going you keep
working and you keep you keep you know
and now I'm creating my own things I
mean I was lazy at writing right which I
wish I hadn't been my whole life and
then in the last over the last like year
or two I realized oh I actually have
this talent to do this thing which I
have you know a couple writing partners
and we're creating our own things which
we're very excited about so um yeah I
think it is it could be cyclical in in
in short ya ya know it just seems like
it just seems like that kind of it seems
like that kind of town you know yeah yes
I think you'd have to hold on I mean
obviously you know if you have talent or
don't have talent there's those people
obviously who come out here and say
maybe they shouldn't be doing this but
if you know in your heart that it's
you're good at it and something you want
to do I think you have to just keep
pushing obviously you have to have some
kind of income source while you're right
you know why you're pushing quiet but
did you question after like the
successes you had like in your teen and
young adult life that whether you're or
not you had it was Talent or whether or
not you you know there was some other
just crazy things you hadn't even really
come into a mindset where you could
probably view your life really in any
sort of whole view yeah well because I
had been working for so long like you
said like family ties in Love Boat and
Fantasy Island and little house and all
that stuff that like I I had always
worked I was always working as a kid
like I would book a lot of [ __ ] and so
it built a confidence in me saying well
I must have some kind of skill here I
wouldn't be getting all this stuff if I
didn't but as far as married with
children goes I mean I really learned
cuz I hadn't done any sitcom before that
like any real comedy I've always played
like the little kid who is crying or the
we're getting divorced and there's
always that heavy [ __ ] and and so when I
got married with children like I've
really learned on the set man like you
know if I watched the first few seasons
I'm like I have I had a lot to learn
right on and I did and then I got better
as the show went on were you like a
player in Hollywood at as a team like
did you tear through a lot of the
starlets of the um I've seen you out
with some post occasionally yeah now
look pretty good I'm curious even back
then like I want to know one person that
you want on a date with that we don't
know oh man I can't I won't I mean I
I've you know I've had my good times
yeah and I and there's a couple out
there that you'd be like holy [ __ ] but I
would never say because I don't want to
be that guy who like isn't like huh
no I don't know that shannen doherty no
no not her Meryl Streep yes yes so tell
our kids that as well tell me about that
marry me children experience my favorite
actual show of all time I saw Nellie
Oleson at a Starbucks and up kind of
each other little house experience yeah
oh the pre experience I remember like
was yesterday even though was only five
years old I don't know why it just
stands out in my mind I have to have a
clear picture of it tremendous
experience Merlin Olsen was on the show
yeah I'm get a [ __ ] hand I just I
still remember the size of his hand I
was like holy [ __ ]
and then dub Taylor of course was was
was there and he was just awesome and
Michael Landon he liked our our family
like his man Michael Landon he used my
sister my brother in two different
projects man two or three different
things I did a hot you know highway to
heaven and stuff he was just just just
an awesome way to heaven
Victor French yeah yeah and he was in
both those series I thought that that
series was amazing I could still see it
on it was great man [ __ ] French
directed the one I did
I don't know I don't know I got lucky
enough to be on it and but the quick
story about that but the the Little
House on the Prairie heat thing is in
one of the scenes I played this mute
writing this family and I played this
little mute couldn't speak and I don't
think there was a custody thing going on
and so the whole thing oh it's your roll
I know right yeah yeah it was this
[ __ ] up and at the very end you know
the court thing goes down I finally look
up but because dub Taylor is trying to
like what do you like adopt me help me
or save me but anyway I look up at him
in the very honest I love you and
there's this tear coming down my ha you
know come on but the point being is
before that there was a scene where I'm
like running through the school and this
girl is supposed to run up and like kiss
me on the cheek and run off and I'm five
years old there's like you know 50 60 70
extras kids and in people and and I was
not gonna have this happen in front of
people like I had refused I dug my heels
in the sand was like no that's not
happening cuz I felt like the other kids
were making fun of me in my mind well
maybe they were I don't know but in my
mind they were all making fun of me so
like production stopped like there was
this whole like okay Michael Landon had
to come down grab my mom we all did take
a little walk and he had the time like
he was so gentle and so cool the way he
did it and he taught me and within like
ten minutes I was like oh yeah okay I'm
cool and then we went about it and did
the scene Wow yeah that was so Michael I
think you would sleep with Michael and I
would never sleep with him dude his son
now would sleep with you though yeah
remember that movie with with that Shia
LaBeouf he's like a big handsome
handsome man it was a handsome man yeah
he was pretty much probably handsomest
man and woman that ever lived that's
really and you got a horse and
everything he really had a lot of
talents that they don't let you know
about I've like in the credits a lot of
times of the shows which would list a
lot of his time juggling heavy smoker
man that's one really [ __ ] is that it's
that
I don't want sure didn't help but he was
always smoking oh you're a dad now I am
married right I'm not married you're not
me or not okay I'm unmarried with child
how is that your new series that's all
right but what I mean I'm not like I'm
with together we live together and you
know we'll probably end up going that
route but right now we're just you know
enjoying our lives enjoying the baby and
she's great she is any of the reason
that you're not married yet I have to do
with being on a show called married with
children um no not I mean like not
everyone do with the example of marriage
I've had in my life including my parents
and my own I was okay um do you uh
is it hard to grow up personally when
you're known as a child on screen yeah I
would say yes to that yeah that's weird
I was very paranoid um you know that's
the other thing I didn't enjoy my fame
as much as I could have hmm excuse me
because I was always always [ __ ]
paranoid because Mara what children
became so huge became such a smash hit
on in season three like first no one
would recognize were for the first two
years I could go anywhere I even wore a
shirt to the mall once that said marry
which other and I was hoping somebody
would you know yeah [ __ ] soul said
anything Wow
so a season threesomes controversy and
then everybody about like something
against women or something like that
this this rich woman named Terry Rakolta
in Detroit saw her kids laughing at the
show and like turned it up you know and
she got coca-cola to pull their
sponsorship as well as McDonald's and it
made these huge headlines and then of
course the hit the show became a smash
hit the producer sent her a thank-you
basket I would say so magazine gave her
[ __ ] of the month just to wrap that
up what was a what are we talking about
so I was always so paranoid man like I
didn't you know wouldn't when it
happened overnight and then everybody I
[ __ ] I hated it I swear to God like oh
I can imagine I bet you probably even
felt into your skin I hate it goin
anywhere I didn't
anyone to look at me I was always hiding
always had [ __ ] hat and sunglasses
and like I just you know I just I just
didn't I didn't enjoy it until I started
to I came out of my shell at about 18
years old then I started to like oh this
is this is how you sort of enjoy success
right just go with it enjoy it don't
like try to fight against it well you
were a child to me you were a kid you
know I mean what 13 me if I'd have been
[ __ ] famous item I can't imagine
I felt like David Schwimmer is all the
time I - when was it was a neighbor of
mine for years he just moved out of the
neighborhood but he's the guy the guy
who's super successful and he's still
the way I was when I was 13 he just he
hates when everybody looks at him and
you know we have tour buses that come
through our neighborhood and you know as
soon as I started coming through he
likes put his house up for sale like
he's just that kind of guy come through
the neighborhood you do you a do you
wear your shirt from which I don't wear
the shirt anymore no but I do once in a
while if I'm out there I'm you know the
guys I'll go out and give a rise but
instigates them once you do once the
drivers that's true you know so but I
don't I'm never really a dick to them
yeah and if I'm out there I say hello
well I mean it's just I mean it really
caught lighting about me so many
millions of people come here and don't
get the opportunity I mean you had 250
something episodes there's no you guys
didn't just to have that happen your
life is on I have one wrap up serious
question with company hurry my serious
wrap-up question is gay at the end what
he does really was there a point in your
life where you felt there was a turning
point from like putting that like I
don't know if it's childhood stardom or
just that youth or the escapades of
youth in Hollywood - okay I gotta get
serious or like now it's about being an
adult or something like that I know I
know you had a run-in with the law
and Labette whatever was it was that a
turning point or was no nothing has yet
been a turning point really
I'm not I don't look I had a child so
things have changed and you know you
learn I've had my my my my run-ins as
you would say but I've been lucky enough
to get away with murder in this in this
life I you know I luckily my huge fame
and that that age came before the world
of the internet and iPhones cameras and
[ __ ] so I was able to act
have fun enjoy it and get away with it
yeah until that one little thing in
Florida Florida's disgusting and all the
kids now do I snapped in cages you're
gonna do we're gonna get there you do to
have the same feeling about Florida I
love God bless you people who live there
but what a horrible [ __ ] saying every
weird story you hear about humanity come
on if you watch if you watch like done
there are oh you don't think of slaves
still in Florida no possible maybe sex
oh I think watch those shows like
Forensic Files every time it starts
Florida in 1977 the Florida it's always
there the [ __ ] happens all right my
funny follow-up is you did a voice on
the gummy bears I did Isis it I used to
sit my grandmother's just sit on the
toilet and watch from the toilet she
would watch Santa Barbara the soap opera
and I would have to sit right outside
the door and long get into y'all but
just you could see it thought about
hosting like a pike at like honestly a
podcast about your hit I mean you have
such a [ __ ] everything we say you have
a story too it's almost amazing well I
do do I do a it's not really a pocke has
more of a radio show I do Scott Scott
what is it on - ski 24/7 which is big
you know he's a big hip-hop DJ out here
he has a he has a radio station called
ski 24/7 so I'm on that it's like
hip-hop themed because I'm a huge
hip-hop fan and so we have a lot of
rappers and producers and stuff like
that but we also have actors I've had
the whole cast Ameria with children oh
that's amazing
yeah it's called old scratch Radio Hour
I should promote that old scratch Radio
Hour and
ready done yeah and you also do you did
you just do real husba real husbands of
Hollywood years ago right
no I oh I did it four years ago but I
just saw some pictures
can we see that oh yeah actually it's
the last episode of the show so period
yes I'll be on with Kevin Hart and Davey
Smith dude dude he's a great guy too oh
he's a sweetest man you know cuz I was a
fan as I never met him before he was not
cuz he was on the show but when I was
there the last two times he was wasn't
working that day so I didn't know if he
was gonna be cool or not all right we
have around three it's really fast and I
know I know he's got to pick a winner of
that round round to the interview rounds
Oh God
I know it's really tough and that's what
your job is I'm gonna go with my man
right here
we're good we're new friends okay
since you have since you have had sus
have since you have had such success in
in voiceover work I want you to give
Matt and I each a description of a
cartoon voice and we're each gonna give
an example of we're gonna try our best
and you decide who did them I'm gonna
give you an example of one from history
it can be no it can be just a couple of
like character yeah any kind okay of any
kind
that's my pitch for what round three
should be I'm gonna go I'm gonna go with
something slightly cliche but evil Lord
of space waiting to take over planet
Earth okay alright and then we each have
ten seconds to do I see you sitting down
there I'm going to come and get you die
alright what was that last die earth
okay a little Asian hey what's up I'm
the evil like space ruler what's up guys
I'm gonna come to earth and hang out
with you because you seem like so much
fun
earth is so colorful I love her yay oh
I'm going with his
yes because you go to a strip joint and
you start you start in Hoboken oh you
expect an evil that's why I can't even
live like this well in other words so
Matt wins that one thank you I
appreciate that
whatever did as a gift for you today we
have from our sponsor is me on DS they
make some really awesome underwear
you've seen their billboards all over
town meet me me me put your meat in oh
you mean you can pick out two pairs of
these these are all fresh and clean they
just yes and the Goins man thank you may
be me I'm me undies thanking me they
actually have great underwear and we
wear them we're all wearing them right
now you and I actually switched our
pairs before the show yeah I turned his
inside out their welcome anything else
you've ever done in your underwear man
anything awesome I've ever done in my
underwear I'm like always in my
underwear so I do a lot of awesome
things and led the way for my snap yeah
I've gone out on said hallo hello to the
tour bus in my in my underwear
no maybe you will so look out he's
certainly might yeah my favorite thing
to do in my underwear is be in my bed
and watch Golden Girls
Golden Girls good well you know what I
will do actually since we're all kind of
just sharing our feelings I'm going to
put my me undies on and I'm gonna watch
I'll probably catch up on a couple of
old seasons of lho pee dude little house
on so thank you very much for coming we
appreciate your a lot of fun shamelessly
give up my social media which is you
know across the board STI n oh except
for snapchat at David Faustino one woo
and also I'm gonna recommend that not
only do you watch David Faustino on
snapchat but you also watch Pauly Shore
as we are here in the in his family's
home at the Comedy Store
the dude is unbelievable he runs around
town tickling Latino people and they
don't know what's going on and
I don't think it's I don't think it's
illegal and I think it's awesome no
Stara collapse Oh up to tune in that's
good David thank you so much man
really a prank
you